SPEAKER: Good afternoon and
welcome to Talks at Google.
We are very pleased to bring
the author and entrepreneur
Ben Parr to campus today.
This Princeton native, that
would be Princeton, Illinois--
being from Champaign,
I definitely
respect that-- was also voted
in 2012 one of the Fortune 30
under 30.
So that's pretty cool.
His career in the
Valley and in tech
has really spanned a
wide variety of areas
from working at "CNET" and
"Mashable" to currently
with "Inc." magazine
and the VC DominateFund.
Today, he's speaking to us
about yonder book, "Captivology,
discusses the
psychology of attention,
and includes a variety of
interviews with thought leaders
on that subject.
It is truly the fundamental
currency of today's economy.
And we'll have some time
at the end for questions,
but for now, Ben Parr, you
now have our attention.
Welcome to Google.
BEN PARR: Thank you.
But you've all seen "Up," right?
And you've seen Doug.
I feel like Doug the
dog, screaming "squirrel"
everywhere all the time.
And we live in this kind of
new era in the last decade
where we are bombarded with
more information than ever.
And yet, we have the
same 24 hours a day.
In 1986, we were presented with
approximately 46 newspapers
worth of information, according
to one research study.
And by 2006, that
number had increased
to 176 newspapers worth.
Today it's actually seven full
HD DVDs worth of information
that we are exposed
to on a daily basis.
And so you combine that
with our multitasking
habitats--that's my
actual TweetDeck.
It looks like someone
vomited on something.
And this is the kind
of thing all of us
are dealing with daily.
And our multitasking habit,
which is not actually
helping us all that much.
In fact, there's
another study that
found that those who consider
themselves heavy multimedia
multitaskers are actually
the least effective
when it comes to completing
tasks and switching
between tasks and accuracy.
And so you have this combination
of way more information
than ever and us
having bad habits
to manage that information.
And you have a world where it
is both extremely difficult
to capture attention and to
stand out with your idea,
whether it's a project, it's
a start up, it's a passion,
it's a charity, and having
it be seen by the world.
And at the same time,
defending our attention
by all of this kind
of information,
understanding which things are
worth our time and attention.
And so that's kind of
the reason, the impetus,
for why I wrote "Captivology."
And "Captivology" is about
the science and the psychology
of attention, and why we pay
attention to certain people
and products, and how to
utilize that science to capture
the attention of others.
And so I'm going to talk a
little bit about the research
I did for "Captivology"--
over 1,000 research
studies, interviews
with dozens of PhDs,
and everybody from Steven
Soderbergh, Adrian Grenier,
the people behind the
Old Spice campaign,
Sheryl Sandberg,
David Copperfield,
people across industries.
I'm going to talk about the
three stages of attention
and my model of attention and,
more importantly, what I call
the seven captivation triggers.
And these are seven
psychological triggers
that capture attention
across all these stages.
And so let me get
into attention.
And so I kind of describe
attention as a bonfire.
And your goal in
capturing attention
is to walk people
through the three stages,
is to grow the fire
because you can't just
start out with a bonfire.
You have to start
with the spark.
And then you go
through the kindling.
And then you go and you finally
get to the logs in the bonfire.
And so the first stage
is immediate attention.
The second stage
is short attention.
And the last stage
is long attention.
And let me explain a little
bit about each stage.
Stage one.
Immediate attention.
It is our immediate
and automatic reaction
to certain sights,
sounds, and stimuli.
It's how we react if someone
does this, for example.
[POP]
I love doing that
every single time.
It's how we automatically react
to when there's sights, sounds,
something like that.
When someone puts a gunshot,
or launches a confetti cannon,
we're going to pay attention.
And I'm sorry to the
janitors in a little bit.
But the reason why we
react is because it's
a defense mechanism.
We're trying to
protect ourselves.
Imagine if you had to
think every time a car was
coming at you.
We'd be dead human beings.
We'd be a dead species.
And so it's a
protection mechanism.
And you'll see that
a lot of attention
is a defense mechanism.
And a lot of it is activating
those defense mechanisms.
The second stage is
from subconscious
automatic attention to
conscious, directed attention,
is when we start concentrating
on something like a test,
or a speaker, or a dress.
That goddamn dress.
But it's when we
actually start focusing.
And it is a kind of
short-term thing.
And it's run by a system
called working memory.
And working memory is this
short-term memory system
that processes the
sights and sounds
around us and the other stimuli
and helps us determine which
things are worth our
time and attention
and, more importantly,
which things should
be stored in long-term memory.
Which leads us-- well, before
I tell you-- very complicated
system, by the way.
I won't go through
the entire process
here, but suffice it to say
it's a very complicated system
that runs our attention.
The final stage of attention is
a stage called long attention.
I kind of use Beyonce
as an example.
It's the difference between
hearing and listening
to a Beyonce song in the
car and joining the Beyhive
and becoming a lifelong
fan and buying albums.
It's the reason why when
Beyonce launched her last album,
she didn't have to
do any marketing.
She just got to drop it and
suddenly everyone bought it.
But it's because she earned
long attention over time,
building those relationships,
building that relationship
with her audience, building
long attention and interest
from millions of people.
And so those three
kind of things
combine to create this
bonfire of attention.
Now how do you build that
bonfire of attention?
You have to go
through what I call
the seven captivation triggers.
And these are seven
psychological triggers
I discovered over and
over again that came up
in my research that
capture attention
from immediate attention
to long attention.
So let me tell you about the
first one-- automaticity.
All right.
So pop quiz.
If you're a hitchhiker
on the side of the road
and you want to have the best
chance of being picked up,
what color shirt
should you wear?
Guesses?
Red, white, I heard.
What else?
Orange.
Yellow.
I've heard everything.
Actually, usually
someone says "naked."
You guys aren't dirty enough.
It's too early in
the day or something?
It's a Monday.
Fair enough.
Maybe during Burning Man.
So the answer is actually,
it's gender specific.
If you're a man, on
average, any bright color
will do because of
the dark backgrounds
of the black roads, and
the dark green grass,
and the brown dirt.
But if you're a woman,
and there was actually
a French scientist who was
like, I'm going to study this.
He wanted to find out who
would get picked up the most.
So he had women wear six
different colored shirts.
And on average, someone
would pull over about 13%
of the time.
Unless they were wearing
the color red, in which case
they were picked
up 21% of the time.
And the reason for that is
actually our subconscious
associations that we have
with red and romanticism.
In fact, another study found if
you just put a thick red border
around a person's face, the
opposite gender, on average,
we'll rate that person
as more attractive.
Reason why there's
a red border there.
I also just like having an
excuse to put that picture up
every time.
But the opposite
gender will rate
that person as more attractive.
And even there was
another study that
found that if a researcher
is wearing a red shirt,
a person who doesn't know will
actually sit several inches
closer to that person.
It's like an automatic
invitation to be more intimate.
And so immediate attention
is this automatic response
to different stimuli.
And it really comes down
to two things-- contrast
and association.
And contrast is the
contrast that something
has with its surroundings, and
association is the subconscious
associations we have with
a certain color, or symbol,
or sound, based on our cultural
history, based on our biology,
based on other factors.
And so a key to capturing
attention with automaticity
is to use the right
color for the job.
So example is Amazon.
There's a reason why they use
yellow and orange buttons.
They have high contrast
with their surroundings,
with white and gray backgrounds.
And they perform really well.
But most bright colors will
actually perform very well.
However, give me some
word association game.
Give me words you think
when you see this.
"Dutch" is usually
the first thing.
Give me more.
Anyone else?
Usually someone says "prison."
But actually, here's my point.
AUDIENCE: White collar prison.
BEN PARR: White
collar-- there you go.
So orange and yellow actually
have the lowest correlation
with competence.
Teal and blue actually
has the highest,
which is why my cover
has blue and teal on it.
But think about it.
If someone like this
walked into most offices,
maybe not Google,
but most offices,
you'd laugh their
ass out of the room.
And it's because of
that correlation.
And there's all these kind
of different correlations
we have with different
colors and sounds.
In fact, let's talk about smell.
So this flower, I believe
the Camellia flower,
was used by Ralph
Lauren in a perfume,
and it performed really well.
So like, let's
expand it everywhere.
So we're going to take
it to South America.
Problem is in South America,
this specific flower
is used in funerals.
So when you sprayed it on, you
literally smelled like death.
How do you think that performed?
Not well is the answer.
Trigger number two-- framing.
And so framing is
that we pay attention
to things that fall within
our frame of reference
or don't pay attention
to things because
of our frame of reference.
And to describe this, I want
to talk about deodorant.
Anyone want some free deodorant?
Specifically, I want to talk
about a teenage entrepreneur
named Edna Murphy.
And so in the 1910s,
deodorant wasn't a thing.
And antiperspirants
weren't a thing.
In fact, this is
what they literally
used to protect themselves--
cotton pads and dress shields.
And there were two reasons why
antiperspirants and deodorants
weren't a popular
thing back then.
First reason was
that people thought
it was going to kill you to use
one, to have antiperspirants.
And it was going to kill you.
But the bigger and second
reason was because it was not
a thing you talked about.
Bodily fluids, sweat, any
of that sort of thing,
it wasn't ladylike.
It was not a thing you talked
about in proper conversation.
And so Edna Murphy, teenage
entrepreneur, her father,
a surgeon, invented an
antiperspirant for his hands
because he wanted to not
sweat doing surgeries.
And she's like, you know, I
could put those in my armpits.
So she does.
And she gets a $500 loan
from her grandfather
and she creates Odo-Ro-No.
Greatest name ever.
In fact, I found one.
I don't think they
make these anymore.
Odo-Ro-No.
So she goes out and
she starts selling
and she gets a little
bit of traction.
But she's finding
it very difficult
to get the product
above that plateau
because of the two reasons
I just told you about.
Now she had to get past it.
So what she did
was she teamed up
with a guy named James Webb
Young who would eventually
become the first chairman
of the Ad Council.
And together they
decided they had
to go in and tackle these
frames of reference,
these perceptions people had.
First, how do you
get people to realize
it will not kill you
to wear antiperspirant.
Well, it was
invented by a doctor.
And so they really
advertised that fact hard.
And this is actually one of
the original advertisements.
And you'll see,
Odo-Ro-No being used
and recommend by leading
physicians skin specialists.
That helped double
sales, when we
started advertising that fact.
But they still had
the bigger issue
of how do you get people
to actually talk about it?
And so they put out this ad.
Now this ad talks very
frankly about body orders.
It says, "a frank discussion of
a subject too often avoided."
And it talks about body odor and
how you don't have to have it.
And how you can use
Odo-Ro-No to fix it.
By the way, this was in
the most popular magazine
of the era, of 1919.
Does anyone want to guess
which magazine that is?
What?
Nope.
Anyone else want to try?
I'm going to take some out
to dinner if they guess this.
No one's ever guessed this.
No.
Answer is "Ladies Home Journal."
And so this was put in
"Ladies Home Journal."
And when it was put in
"Ladies Home Journal,"
it was actually one of the most
controversial things if 1919.
Hundreds of women canceled
their "Ladies Home Journal"
subscriptions in
protest of this ad.
But guess what?
The ad changed people's
frame of reference.
They started actually
talking about deodorants.
And suddenly it was OK to
talk about antiperspirants.
And sales went through the roof.
And a few years
later, Edna Murphy
was able to sell her
company for millions.
And so what she did was she
adapted her audience's frame
of reference.
And she helped re-frame
the conversation.
And Odo-Ro-No did this
by adapting to the fact
that people were worried
about health concerns
so they brought in the fact
that a doctor invented it.
And they re-framed
the conversation
by making it OK to discuss.
And so frames of
reference and framing
is this incredible power in
which we can pay attention
to certain things and not
others based on our backgrounds
and worldview.
It's the reason why if you
talk about climate change
or you talk about
vaccines, one group
is going to have a
very different reaction
than another.
And in a funny way, it
does make sense sometimes
because if someone comes
to us and is telling us
how the earth is flat, why the
fuck should we listen to them?
It makes sense, but
then sometimes we
get into this kind of rut
where we miss important things.
There are a couple ways to
create frames of reference
and to change
frame of reference.
One big one is scarcity.
So who likes Twinkies here?
Oh, thank God.
No one.
But Twinkies, as you
probably may remember,
a few years ago, the
company that owned them,
Hostess, went bankrupt, right?
And suddenly, millions of
people went to the stores
to grab these things.
And it was not for the reason
that they tasted any better.
They still tasted like shit.
But suddenly, they
became very popular.
And the reason,
actually, the science
shows that we assign
higher value to things
that we feel are scarce.
Specifically, when
we believe something
is scarce due to
outside circumstances.
If something is scarce
because it is popular,
it does not raise
in value and we
don't pay more attention to it.
But if something is scarce
because of an outside force,
because of a manufacturing
or some other thing,
we assign much more value.
In a Google example, let's
think about Gmail invites.
I actually, someone paid
me $100 once for one
of my original Gmail invites.
I was like, why the
f--oh, here you go.
Thank you for the $100.
But that scarcity element
does drive attention
and drives a different
frame of reference.
Trigger number
three-- disruption.
We pay attention to the things
that violate our expectations.
And I'll explain
why in a moment.
So there's this
one research study
where they want to
see which things would
stick in the memory longest.
And so they would give
subjects different sentences.
Standard ones like, the
maids were plating the food
on the table versus
the maid licked
the ammonia off the floor.
Now which one do you think
people had a better memory for?
It's actually a scientific term
called the bizarreness effect.
And the reason we
remember this is actually
because of something called
violations expectancy theory.
So imagine, for example,
we're on a date.
All right.
And we're just like sitting down
and suddenly, two giant clowns
come and just sit down
right next to us, right?
We're going to be paying
attention to them.
But the reason why is because
we make an automatic threat
assessment.
We have to figure out whether
this is a positive development
or we should run the fuck away.
Maybe this is our
good friends who
are about to go visit
a children's hospital
or maybe they're about to mug
us and we're about to die.
Either way, we're going to
turn our attention to something
that violates our
expectations because we
have to protect ourselves.
If you think about
how we originally
were as hunter gatherers when
our attention was scanning,
we were looking for things
that were out of place.
Maybe it's a saber tooth tiger,
maybe it's a potential food.
We have the same
kind of instincts.
And that's why we pay
attention to things
that violate our expectations.
And there's a couple examples,
especially in advertising,
that work really well.
This is a campaign a couple
years ago from Patagonia.
They did a campaign.
It was called Don't
Buy This Jacket.
They're a clothing company.
They're not supposed
to fucking say that.
But they explain, when
you go into the ad
deeper for that,
the reason they're
saying this is
because they don't
want people to unnecessarily
buy more stuff.
They want to help repair
your clothing if you can.
And of course, they'll sell you
a jacket if your jacket is old.
But they'll help you
repair and they want
to protect the environment.
Funny enough, this ad telling
people not to buy their stuff
made more people buy
their stuff-- double
the amount within nine months.
A whole ton of people
started buying their jackets
because people paid attention.
It was a positive experience.
The Old Spice guy's another
great example of this.
Of positive destruction.
Every five seconds diamonds
are suddenly coming out
of people's hands
and he's suddenly
on horses and diving into
cakes and who knows what else.
But it's a very kind
of positive experience.
And every few
seconds something is
happening different
that violates
your expectations of how the
world is supposed to work.
The disruption has to match your
values is a very key thing I
want to mention.
There is such a
thing as positive
versus negative attention.
I think about what Nationwide
did at the Super Bowl
commercial.
And the only thing I
think of Nationwide
now is that
Nationwide kills kids.
Now I'm going to show you the
actual ad from a few years ago.
This one.
This was an ad for Quiznos.
And they had weird, freaky,
mutant, fucking rodents
advertising sandwiches.
Why the fuck would you want any
of these things near your food?
How does that make
any sense at all?
And yet, a bunch
of execs decide,
you know what, this is
going to be a great idea.
They went bankrupt last year.
There is such a thing
as negative attention.
This make no sense at all.
It did not match their values.
It was disruptive.
People paid attention.
But it didn't make people
buy their sandwiches.
There is a clear difference.
Trigger number four-- reward.
And so I learned some
interesting things
about the reward
mechanisms of the brain.
Most people think of
dopamine as the system
that creates pleasure but that's
actually a misunderstanding.
I interviewed Dr. Kent
Barich, a leading researcher
in dopamine and reward
systems of the brain.
And what he did is
this famous experiment
where he took the
dopamine out of lab mice
and he wanted to see
what would happen.
And what he found was that the
mice could still feel pleasure
even with no dopamine.
If you gave the
mouse sugar water,
it would still find pleasure
drinking the sugar water.
What happened though was that
the mice lost all motivation.
These mice were so demotivated,
in fact, that they would rather
starve to death than eat.
And almost all of them died
because they had no motivation
to live or to find
any kind of survival.
And so dopamine actually
creates wanting.
It creates a wanting
response in the brain.
Opioids actually create
the actual pleasure.
But when it comes to
attention, what's important
is our desire for something.
We pay attention to
when we desire a reward,
whether it is an intrinsic
or extrinsic reward.
Extrinsic rewards are
the kind of physical ones
that you're very well familiar
with-- money, food, sex.
Very, very, clear things.
And they really do capture our
attention in the short term.
In fact, there was
a study that found
that if you associate an
object with monetary gain,
with money, even
just a few cents,
people's eyes will automatically
gravitate towards that object,
even after that object is no
longer associated with money.
But that's only
short term attention.
Short attention.
That doesn't capture
attention over the long term.
Intrinsic rewards capture
Things like self satisfaction
and purpose and mastery
and these kind of
self type of things
that motivate us in our jobs,
in our careers, in our lives.
And family and order
and whatever things that
motivate you.
Those are the kinds
of things that
make people stay long term.
You need both to capture
and maintain attention.
But you can't just use one
or the other and succeed.
And there are a couple
ways to create motivation
and to create
desire for a reward.
One is the power of surprise.
And so a couple years ago,
a company called Skopje,
they wanted to
get more engineers
because it is obviously a
very, very competitive market.
And so they're like, how do
we get some more engineers?
They're going to offer a bonus
of $11,000 for signing up.
That's kind standard.
But they decided,
you know, what we're
going to parody the most
interesting man in the world
campaign.
So they wrapped $11,000
in cash in bacon.
And then they
would also give you
Macoun 15, a oil
painting of yourself,
and my favorite, a harpoon gun.
I don't know about you,
but I want a harpoon gun.
Can I get a harpoon gun?
That would be nice.
So this actually, this
campaign, got them
over 1,000 different
applications.
And they were able to fill
their engineering seats.
And so that surprise actually
helps capture attention
when it comes to rewards.
But it's also just the
fact of surprising people
with a reward.
And so there was
a study that was
done-- there was a
study that what happened
was that they
would have subjects
and they would
spray either water
or citrus into their mouths.
And what they found was that
the people who could not
predict the order in which
citrus or water were going
to be sprayed into the mouths
felt much more pleasure,
had stronger member of
the task, and overall
paid more attention.
It was a much more positive
and pleasant experience.
And so most people deliver
rewards in incentive form.
You do this, I'll give you this.
And that is actually the least
effective type of reward.
There many other better
types are rewards.
There's a company
called Keep and what
they do is they specialize
in post action rewards.
And what happens is
like, you do a task.
Like you run two miles, you
get a high score in a game,
and suddenly something
pops up being like,
you've accomplished something.
We want to give you a gift.
A surprise gift.
Maybe it's a Gatorade,
maybe it's an extra life,
maybe it's some points.
But that kind of surprise,
where people didn't expect
to get a reward
actually reinforces
behavior much
stronger and increases
attention and overall
is much stronger
when it comes to attention.
Practically every other type
of reward delivery is better.
Gifting, for example--
you're very used to it,
like in a social game being able
to give a life to your friends.
Even though, as
you think about it,
you're not actually giving
anything to your friends.
It's actually coming
from the game.
It just makes it look
like it's coming from you.
But it actually creates
much more attention
because it feels like it's a
more personal sort of thing.
Sneaky.
Trigger number
five-- reputation.
So I'm going to put this on
while we talk about reputation
in this interesting study.
So a few years ago, there was
a study at Emory University
and what they did
was they looked
at the FMRIs of
students' brains as they
were making economic decisions.
I'm putting on a lab coat.
I'll explain why in a moment.
So they were looking at
the FMRIs of students
and they were
trying to figure out
how the brain works while during
decision making in economics.
And so they would have to
make economic decisions
with their money.
And as you could expect, the
critical thinking decision
centers of the
brain would light up
whenever they were making
decisions with their money.
And this is the
actual brain scans.
But in half the cases, they
would have an expert come in
to give advice.
In this case, an
economics professor.
And it would always be
the conservative advice.
And what they found was
when a subject was listening
to the expert, the decision
making centers of their brain
would completely shut off.
It was as if they offloaded
the processing power
of their brains to the expert.
And in fact, even
when the advice
that the expert was
giving was clearly wrong,
the subjects would more often go
with that advice than the other
because they're not thinking.
And this is a phenomenon
known as directed deference.
And directed deference
helps drive our attention.
And so the reputation
triggers that we pay attention
to repeatable sources,
specifically authority figures,
the crowd, and most
of all, experts.
In fact, and this
is a fun study,
if someone puts on a doctor's
coat and you tell them
it's a doctor's coat,
and they do tasks,
on average they will
have better attention,
they will make less mistakes,
and they will complete tasks
more effectively.
Now if you give them
the very same coat
and you tell them
it's a painter's coat,
their attention will actually
go in the opposite direction.
And they will
complete less tasks
and they'll be less effective.
The mere perception of
expertise increases attention.
That's why I'm wearing the coat.
And so as I said before,
there are three key types
of reputable sources
that we pay attention to.
Authority figures
have power over us
and so we pay attention
as long as they
have that power over us.
And the crowd kind of
acts like an expert.
And you think about sites
like Yelp or a lot of others
where we go into those
the sites for ratings
and we trust their
ratings because
of the collective
knowledge of the crowd.
And we trust the crowd.
So there's another reason why
we trust reputable sources
and experts.
And the answer is actually
from this Edelmen Trust Survey.
We trust them more than any
other type of spokesperson.
And so you can see here the
most credible spokesperson out
of thousands and thousands of
people surveyed are experts.
More than people like
you, more than executives,
and definitely more than CEOs.
We really, really trust experts.
And government officials are
somewhere in the basement
where they belong.
And so key brands and
capturing attention
really revolves around
leveraging experts,
and leveraging the
power of experts,
and establishing your
credibility as an expert
as well.
Odo-Ro-No did this by
leveraging the fact that it
was created by a doctor.
And leveraging the fact that
it was created by a doctor.
And this is also the
same kind of reason
why things like Kickstarter
do very well because it's
the crowd's expertise showing
that a specific thing is
worth our attention and time.
Two more triggers.
Trigger number six.
I can take this coat off.
It's kinda hot.
I'm stripping for you all.
You're welcome.
Mystery.
So what movie is this?
Anyone want to guess?
That's right. "Cloverfield."
So I don't have time to
show the entire trailer
of "Cloverfield."
But in the first trailer of
"Cloverfield," what happens
is there's people at a party,
suddenly there's a roar
and then the Statue of Liberty's
head falls into the street.
There's no mention
of the movie's name
or what it's called
or what it's about.
And this is a huge impetus
of the mystery trigger.
And this is a JJ Abrams movie.
He's a master at mysteries.
At both using mysteries to
market his material because
for example, we know barely
anything about "Star Wars"
and that's what he wants.
And also in his storytelling.
For "Lost," for example, famous
for having that cliffhanger
that would get people to
come back week to week.
And so there are actually
two scientific reasons why
mysteries capture attention.
The first is something
called the Zeigarnik Effect.
So in the 1950s, there was
this Soviet researcher.
Her name is Bluma Zeigarnik.
And she is sitting
in a restaurant
and she's curious
about something.
The waiters who are
taking her order
have perfect memory
of her orders
until they actually drop
it off over at the kitchen,
and suddenly, completely forget.
Now why is that?
She's curious.
So she gets a bunch of
students and a bunch of kids
and she has them do puzzles.
But in half the case studies,
she takes their puzzles away.
That's mean, right?
A couple months later,
she would ask them
which puzzles they
would remember.
And guess what.
The only puzzles
they could remember,
the only tasks
they could remember
were the ones that
were incomplete.
We have a much stronger memory
for incomplete the tasks,
incomplete thoughts,
incomplete storylines.
Zeigarnik Effect.
Now there's a second reason.
Now, let's pretend you
and I are on a date.
Actually, we'll go on a date.
We've been on a date before.
So pretend we're on a date.
Now if we're on a first
date, what we're going to do,
typically, is small talk, right?
Kind of things like where are
you from, what do you like,
that sort of thing.
And the reason why we do that
is actually because of a thing
called uncertainty
reduction principal.
And essentially, we don't
like uncertainty in our lives.
It makes us uncomfortable.
And we meet a stranger, there's
nothing but uncertainly.
We don't know anything
about each other.
And so what we're
trying to do is
relieve the uncertainty so we
can figure out whether or not
I want to hang out
with this person
or be friends or get the
fuck away as far as I can.
All depends, right?
And so in the case of
uncertainty reduction
principle, it applies
all across the board.
When we're left
with a cliffhanger
and we're left
with a mystery, we
want to relieve
that uncertainty.
We want to resolve
that storyline.
And then when we don't,
we start filling it
in with speculation
and uncertainty.
The Malaysian Airlines
disaster last year
is a perfect example of this.
It's not the first
time a plane went down.
But planes aren't
supposed to disappear.
And so when this
one disappeared,
suddenly, it was on
the media for months.
Why?
Because we don't
like uncertainty,
so we start filling
with speculation.
Especially CNN.
They loved filling
it with speculation.
Thank you, CNN.
And they kept filling it
with all this speculation.
Trying to-- what's going on?
Where did it go?
All that sort of thing.
And the reason, again,
why is because we do not
like that uncertainty.
We have to fill it in.
It's the same reason
also why, for example, I
don't know if anyone remembers
a year ago, Justine Sacco.
She was an exec at IAC.
And she before she
gets on the plane she
decides to tweet something
along the lines of "I'm
going to Africa.
Hope I don't get AIDS.
Oh and wait.
I'm white."
She does this.
She gets on a plane.
And then she's off Wi-Fi.
By the time she
gets off the plane,
she's the number one
trending topic in the world
and she's the most
reviled person on Twitter.
And the reason why is
because she couldn't
close the uncertainty gap.
She couldn't close
the mystery loop.
Everyone started
filling speculation
of how is she going to react?
Who is this person?
Why would she say such a thing?
In fact, Steve Martin
tweeted something offensive
as well in the same
time period but nothing
happened to him because
he was able to delete
his Tweet within two
minutes and post an apology.
Mystery done.
Justine Sacco could
not and that's
why she became the number
one trending topic.
And so there are a couple things
when you think about mysteries
to capture attention.
The mystery trigger.
One is to create suspense.
And I don't think
the sound is working,
but we're going to
try a video anyway.
This was one of
the Budweiser ads
from this year's Super Bowl.
And I love any reason to add
puppies to a conversation.
And in this case, this was
one of the most popular ads.
And part of the reason
is because of suspense.
And so you know that Budweiser's
not going to kill the puppy.
They're not Nationwide.
But there is this moment to
moment suspense of what's
going to happen
to the puppy, how
is it going to
escape the wolves,
how is it going
to get back home.
And there was a
study that actually
found that the more
moment to moment suspense
we feel in an advertisement,
the more memory we're
going to have it, the
more we'll pay attention,
and the more positive reaction
we'll have to that ad.
And that's part
of the reason why
I believe this one was one
of the most popular ones
of this year's Super Bowl.
And so another tool for
capturing attention.
Can't do another one even
tough I love the puppies.
So another key tool
is using cliffhangers.
And so creating the
cliffhangers, whether it's
in advertising, or
in your storytelling,
or maybe just a cliffhanger
to get people to come back
to the next meeting.
Captures attention again
because of that uncertainty gap.
You should use cliffhangers
when you can unless you're
going through a press crisis.
Like that guy.
So everyone knows that
guy or most of you
know that guy, maybe.
And this is Brian Williams.
And what happened with
him was he basically
lied about what happened
when he was in the war zone.
And he put out what amounted
to a half-assed apology.
It was kind of like, "I sort
of mis-remembered, blah, blah,
blah."
What it didn't do was
complete the mystery gap
and complete the mystery.
And so people filled in with
speculation until suddenly,
more reports came out to a
point where he had to step down.
On the other hand, regardless
of what you think of this guy,
there was no mystery gap.
When his allegations
came out, he
came out hard and being like,
here's exactly fact ABC.
Go look.
That's it.
Done.
And guess what?
He still has a job.
Again, regardless of
what you think of him,
he's still in his chair
and Brian Williams is not.
But there's actually a
couple good tech examples
of this as well.
So a couple years
ago, Airbnb-- I
don't know if anyone remembers
this-- but they had a renter.
They had a gal named EJ and
she rented out her place
and she came back
and it was completely
ransacked-- destroyed,
burned, everything stolen.
And Airbnb was kind of
slow to helping her our
in fixing the problem.
So she wrote a
blog post about it.
It went viral.
Everyone wrote about it.
And when it started
going viral, Airbnb
felt like it had to respond.
So Brian Chesky wrote
that on Hacker News, which
basically says, "hi, everyone.
We were shocked when we heard
about this unsettling event.
We have been working closely
with the authorities, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
It is written by a lawyer.
It sounds like a lawyer.
There is no apology.
It doesn't resolve jack shit.
Guess what?
The mystery continued.
EJ put out another post.
The thing went more viral.
Airbnb looked even worse
until finally, they
put out the right statement.
They put out this blog post.
This one, which said, like,
with EJ, we got this wrong.
We let her down.
And we are sorry.
And we fucked up.
And here's how we're
going to fix it.
When they did that,
the story was over
because they completed
the mystery loop,
the gap of uncertainty was
filled and the story died.
And so when it comes to
a press crisis like that,
your number one goal
is to end the mystery.
Exactly here is we
fucked up and here's
how we're going to fix it.
Final trigger.
And then questions, if
you have any questions.
Think about your questions now.
Acknowledgement.
The most powerful of my
captivation triggers.
And so there was this
one study that-- yeah,
it was pretty cruel, actually.
And what they did was
they strapped electrodes
to the ankles of married women.
Yeah, pretty much.
And there were three conditions.
Condition one.
Married woman sitting alone.
Condition two.
Married woman could hold
the hand of a stranger.
Condition three.
Married woman could hold
the hand of her husband.
And so what they
found was that when
the married women who had
no one to hold the hand of
felt the most pain
because they had nowhere
to direct their attention.
And the married women who
could hold the husband's hands
felt the least pain
because they had
someone they love to direct
their attention towards.
But what I found
fascinating about this study
was that there was
a direct correlation
between the strength of the
marriage and the amount of pain
that these women felt.
The more connected they felt
to their spouse, the less pain
they felt.
And it kind of shows how
powerful this acknowledgement
and this connection is.
This connection is so
powerful that it can
reduce an even eliminate pain.
And so the key to the
acknowledgement trigger
is that we pay attention to
the people and things that
pay attention to us and
provide us with validation,
empathy, and understanding.
And one example of
this is actually
in our celebrity culture.
And so this is Adrian Grenier
from the show "Entourage"
and this is Dr.
Thomas de Zengotita.
And I interviewed them
for "Captivology."
And you wouldn't think that they
would be experts in anything
like this, but actually, they
did a documentary together
called "Teenage Paparazzo" on
a 15-year-old teenage paparazzi
and following him
around and exploring
why we pay attention to
celebrities and celebrity
culture.
And we had this long
conversation about why.
And we kind of came
to the conclusion,
one of the major reasons we
pay attention to celebrities
is because they're, in a way,
a reflection of ourselves.
They are a piece
of our identity.
It says something about
you, whether you're
a fan of Justin
Bieber or Rachel Ray
or Sheryl Sandberg or
an Apple or a Google
or a whichever company.
It says something about
you and your identity.
And we are looking for
things that validate
our identity in some way.
In fact, actually,
Buzzfeed, for example--
I interviewed Jonah
Peretti the CEO Buzzfeed--
and what I learned
from them is that they
do a lot of this kind
of validation aspect.
One article that I
read about is that they
did was "54 Things
That Minnesotans Are
Too Humble To Brag About."
Now, this article went viral,
especially in Minnesota,
as you could imagine.
But the reason why
is because it's
a validation, a positive
affirmation of a key identity,
for a key demographic.
And it's saying it's great
to be from Minnesota.
And Buzzfeed puts these
articles and these quizzes
out all the time.
'90s Kids or from Chicago
or works in X industry.
They do this all the time.
And it's always very positive.
They affirm.
They go for EQ over IQ.
And it works really well for
capturing attention for them.
So there's actually
a term for all this,
and especially for our
relationship with celebrities.
It's called the
parasocial relationship.
And so it is our capability
to feel a two-way relationship
with a one-way figure.
And I'll give an example.
There is-- my old
boss at "Mashable,"
she works for Rachel Ray now.
And what happened
was Rachael Ray
came out for Obamacare, right?
And what suddenly
happened was there
was a whole bunch of women
who came out and they're like,
how could you do this?
You've betrayed me.
I thought I knew you.
The fuck?
How does this make any sense?
It makes sense
because people can
feel as deep of a
connection with a figure
like that as they can with their
best friend or their families.
Parasocial relationship.
It's why we can fall
in love with a brand
or a musician or an artist.
And the case, for
example, of Taylor Swift.
She's a master at
parasocial relationships.
So last year, she was
doing YouTube videos.
And it was YouTube videos
of her wrapping gifts
and sending it to
a few of her fans.
And this created a frenzy
in her entire community.
She didn't have to give a
gift to every single member
of her community, to all
over fans-- just a few
to show that she cared
about them as a collective.
And as a result, they
paid attention back
and made her album the number
one album of last year.
She did a fantastic job
of building that community
and building that relationship.
And she scaled her relationship
with her community.
Now there are a
couple other ways
to build that kind of
identity and that validation
and that acknowledgement.
And it is this way.
It is through the
power of participation.
So some of you may
know this story.
In the 1950s, Betty Crocker
and all the big cake mixing
and food mixing companies at
the time like Duncan Hines
and Pillsbury, they were trying
to get cake mix off the ground.
But cake mix wasn't taking off
with the female demographic,
not like Bisquik did.
And they were stumped.
Betty Crocker's
like, why is this not
being getting
bought by everybody.
So they brought
in two researchers
to come in and give them
advice on what's going on.
And they figured
it out, actually.
The reason why it wasn't
taking off was eggs.
Now back then, eggs actually
came in powdered form.
You could just have the powdered
eggs, you just put it in.
You didn't have to have
the fresh eggs with you.
And in fact, if you
actually try these recipes,
there really isn't
much a difference
between a powdered
egg and a fresh egg.
But what they found
was that women
didn't feel like
they were making
any contribution to the recipe
in the cake mix version.
And so what Betty Crocker
did was literally make
their product harder to use.
And the result was that their
sales went through the roof
and they won the
cake mixing wars
by making it so that you had
to break eggs into the recipe.
And it worked
really, really well
because they enabled
their audience
to participate and provide
some kind of validation,
to provide their input.
It's the same kind of
reason, for example,
why Kickstarter is so powerful.
Yes, Exploding Kittens.
I can't wait to get my deck.
And it's because not just
are you buying something--
it's pretty much
a buying website--
but you feel like that you're
providing some kind of input.
You are helping a company
get off the ground.
You are providing
something extra.
You are part of that community.
A couple years ago, I remember,
Vitamin Water-- they actually
asked their community
to help name
the next flavor of Vitamin
Water and actually create
the next flavor.
And it was a campaign
and it went really viral.
And they allowed their
audience to put their input.
And they eventually
came up with one called
"Connect," based off Facebook.
And it did really well and
their sales went up as a result,
again because they allowed
their community to participate
and that alone created
that acknowledgement
with their audience.
And so I've talked about
the seven key triggers.
Automaticity, framing,
disruption, reward, reputation,
mystery, and acknowledgement.
And you'll kind of
notice that these
triggers go across all
three stages of attention.
Automaticity is very powerful
in immediate attention,
while disruption is a very
powerful trigger for capturing
short attention, while mysteries
and acknowledgement are
powerful tools for
long attention,
get people to have
long term interest.
Because it's not
enough to just get
people to pay attention
to your ad or to your idea
or to your campaign.
But you need people to become
customers and users and fans.
And the last thing I
will say that I learned
from this process is
from all the interviews
I did with all these
masters of attention
is that the masters of attention
don't try to capture attention
for themselves.
They're trying to get
attention for their products,
their projects, and their ideas.
They're not trying
to be me, me, me.
They're trying to get a cause
and to promote something
that is bigger and beyond them.
And that is a much more powerful
version and much more powerful
form of attention.
And I guess that is a
sign that it's done.
So you know what?
Thank you, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I am Darcy.
I am a hardware
reliability engineer,
and I'm curious about this
colors and competency study
thing.
Is that dependent on culture?
BEN PARR: It is
dependent on culture.
And so I didn't mention in
this part of the presentation
but the cultural associations
really do impact color.
I was talking specifically
about US and Western.
Couple different examples.
Green is terrible
packaging in China
because green is associated with
funerals and death in China.
And in fact, it is a very poor
performing packaging color
in that country.
Red has significantly
different associations
across different cultures.
There are a few things
that are the same.
Like for example, blue.
If you, for example, there was
a study that actually found
that if you put schizophrenics
under blue light, regardless
of which culture,
they will be calmer
and they will be more relaxed.
And if you put them
in a red light,
they will be more energetic
and they'll be more jumpy
and they'll be more agitated.
So there are some
that are universal.
But there's a lot that are
different culture by culture.
And I actually provide
some resources in the book
and some links and examples
of different colors
in different cultures.
And there's actually
an amazing color wheel
that shows the associations
different cultures have
with different cultures.
The reason why I
focus so much on color
is because color provides the
majority of initial assessment
when people are
looking at a brand.
If people look at a
symbol for the first time,
the majority of their assessment
will be purely from the color
as well.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
a video game designer.
And I just wanted
to let you know
that I had seen
something very similar
that somebody had
described in trying
to figure out how to get people
to play early arcade video
games.
A woman ran a company
and she talked
about the first quarter,
the second quarter,
and the thousandth quarter.
And the idea that it's first
getting their attention
and then having them
have that reaction of OK,
I played it once.
Now I want to try it again.
And then having
something in there
that keeps them going
1,000 quarter drops later.
And just the games
industry looks
at trying to keep people's
attention particularly
on social media games, as
you mentioned, like the stuff
on Facebook.
So it seems like there are a lot
of commonalities in what you're
talking about there.
BEN PARR: Exactly.
One of the people I
interviewed and one
of my favorite
interviews for the book,
is Shigeru Miyamoto, the
creator of Super Mario.
And I got to interview
him at E3 a few years ago.
And he talked me
through why Mario
captures so much attention
across all three stages.
So I don't know if
you all know this,
but the original Super
Mario, when they first
created the character, they
only had 16 by 16 pixels.
And they're like, how do we
make this guy more distinctive?
How do we have him
pop out on the screen?
Well, we got to make his nose
big because that's the only way
to see he even has a nose.
So they made his nose big.
But you couldn't
even tell he had
a nose so they put a
mustache on it so you
could define the nose.
Now it was impossible to
do hair in 16 by 16 pixels.
So we're going to
give him a red cap.
And a shirt didn't really pop
out at all, shirt and pants,
so they gave him overalls.
And that's actually why Super
Mario has big nose, moustache,
a hat, and overalls.
But that's just
immediate attention.
They really focused on that
kind of gameplay element,
getting people to try to
achieve the reward of getting
that high score,
getting to the end
of that level, and that
loop every single time,
within a specific game.
But the reason why we play every
Mario game and love and all
that sort of thing is
because we fall in love
with the characters.
We know the key elements
of every single Mario game.
There's always
going to be Koopas.
There's always going
to be gold coins.
There's always going to
be a Bowser somewhere.
And that kind of element makes
us come back for each game
because we have the familiarity.
While each game is different
enough in terms of game
play to make us
find something new.
Whether it's going to a Mario
galaxy or a new platform
or that sort of thing.
And so that's part
of why Mario has
become an icon over decades.
And so many other games
have fallen by the wayside.
AUDIENCE: I am wondering
what suggestions
you have for getting people to
pay attention to and not only
pay attention to,
but take action
in regard to
environmental issues,
such as water conservation
and climate change.
BEN PARR: Oh.
Oh.
I mean, I went through a
lot of framing research
to think about that one.
Because there's a couple
things that go about it.
It's really a
framing issue, right?
It's elevating the
importance of that knowledge
to a level where people will be
forced to pay attention, right?
Because there's
a whole-- there's
a segment of the population
that absolutely and thank
God believes that we
have huge issues coming
with water conservation
and climate change.
And yet, there's
still a huge part
of the population
that will not even
listen to you if you mention
these things because they have
been indoctrinated
with years of hearing
a different side of the story.
Now there's a couple different
ways to kind of go about it.
You can find a way to adapt
to the frame of reference
and not go directly and
be like, you're wrong.
Because that will
actually not work.
You have to find a
way to get actually
them to agree on a little thing
and that actually opens up
the door lot more.
You get them to agree
on the smallest thing
and that will make them
more receptive to an idea.
There's a couple other things.
One interesting
thing I learned is
the illusion of truth effect.
And this might not necessarily
help you get attention for it,
but it'll help
you understand why
people believe what they do.
And it is purely that the
more you repeat a phrase,
the more likely people
will believe it is true.
And they did a study
where they would
have people go through like
30 or 40 phrases every couple
weeks and they would
rate how true they were.
And every time they
went through it,
they would rate the statements
that they saw over and over
again as more true,
despite the fact
that repeating a
statement does not
make a thing more or less true.
But it actually has that
kind of profound effect
in our brains and our minds.
And so when it comes
to getting attention
for that sort of
thing, it's going
through those three stages.
It's how do you get
people to pay attention
to it in the first place?
If they don't know anything
about it, disruption trigger.
Getting people to violate
their expectations
with something that'll
make them turn their heads.
I think about anti
smoking campaigns.
In Thailand, they
had a campaign where
they had little kids with
cigarettes in their mouths,
asking adults for lights that
had cigarettes in their mouths.
And the adults would be like,
you shouldn't be smoking.
It's causes cancer.
And the kids would be like,
then why are you smoking it?
And that went viral not just
in Thailand but all across
because it violated
people's expectations,
and it really drove
the point home.
But then, it kind of
comes in long term.
It depends on the audience
that you're really going for.
I suspect that you
have a huge group.
There's one group that just
will not believe what you say.
And it's going to
require different tactics
and you have to really think
about the framing trigger.
And you have this audience
that thinks it's important
but maybe they're not
being active enough.
And they know that
there's sort of a problem,
but they don't think
of it strong enough.
And I think that maybe have
to violate their expectations
and jolt them out of their
complacency and be like, here
is what is effing happening.
And I'm not sure what
that kind of thing
is but you need to jolt them
out of their expectations.
I would love to
talk about that one
further because that's a
hard problem that I still
haven't fully figured out
how we solve that one.
All right.
I think that's good.
So if you want to ask
me more questions,
feel free to email me or tweet
at me or Google+ me or all that
other fun stuff.
And I hope you'll
check out the book
because it has a lot more
of that scientific research
and interesting stories
and more tips on how
you capture attention and
how attention really works.
So I want to thank you all
for being an awesome audience.
[APPLAUSE]